hi i'm owen wilson and this is the wired
auto complete interview
[Music]
no i have not googled myself
i can't think of anything
worse how did owen wilson get his start
i guess university of texas wes anderson
and i became friends and college
roommates and then we started writing a
screenplay together that became bottle
rocket how did owen wilson get his nose
broken uh at university of texas yeah
playing uh we're doing intramural flag
football and i got bang but also i think
just like as a kid just rough
roughhousing
how many movies are owen wilson and ben
stiller in together i don't know feels
like 70. you know because we have a lot
of sequels and stuff so we have the meet
the parents so there's three we have the
night at the museums that's three right
there although ben was never there at
night at the museum because you know
steve coog and i play these little
miniature characters so uh they didn't
need him there then we were in royal
tenon bombs and starsky and hutch and
the first movie uh
uh permanent midnight i feel like
there's one more but that's nine right
there actually twelve
12 movies there's 12 yeah with ben what
am i leaving out oh yeah zoolanders yeah
how could i forget that yeah yeah we had
two zoolanders i think it's 11 but uh
but they're telling me 12. okay
how many movies are owen wilson and
vince vaughn in together wedding
crashers of course and zoolander
and
[Music]
oh an internship so it's just three four
four star
oh he was like yeah that's right he's
really funny
he kind of does a little dancing thing
in the bar mitzvah scene
uh that makes me laugh let's go right
here
is owen wilson in every wes anderson
movie no i'm not i wasn't in moonrise
kingdom and i wasn't in a few others i
guess my favorite i mean i always have a
soft spot for bottle rocket the first
one
but then darjeeling limited i think the
story kind of about three brothers was
something that um of course i can relate
to
and i just love being in india so maybe
that's my favorite is owen wilson
australian yes
he is g'day
do they think that is that something
they think
i think that's kind of nice because
australians kind of
uh they sort of have the reputation of
sort of a kind of a hail fellow well met
and maybe there is sort of i'm from
texas and maybe there is a slight
overlap in um kind of the brashness of
texans and australians i like a lot of
australian movies and um and i've had
fun being there so yeah let's say yes
okay next one
is owen wilson a good skateboarder you
know this one people think a lot that
i'm a skateboarder because i did this
escape video yeah right that spike jones
uh directed i do a trick in it that
people think is me but some people say
it's eric coston and they did a cowboy
switch and it wasn't me but um i think
it was me is owen wilson coming back to
loki um
yes he is coming back to loki and i
think we're gonna start filming that
pretty soon i had a great time working
on loki i really enjoyed tom hiddleston
and all the people on that
it's very satisfying doing that who was
older luke or owen wilson that would be
i'm older i'm three years older than
luke was owen wilson in a fraternity
decidedly not in a fraternity i didn't
graduate from college were you in the
frat talk though that's kind of like a
fraternity of um
yeah was that what did they call that
they
no i think the frat
wasn't that the thing with rob lowe and
emilio estevez in them i think they
that's what got called the frat pack but
maybe the group of comedians that they
talk about sort of
ben stiller and jack black i forget what
the name was for that but um yeah maybe
i was a member of that i wouldn't want
to be a member of any club that would
have someone like me as a member what's
that joke was owen wilson a model
no i wasn't
who
what does this one mean what's this one
who is your daddy owen wilson my father
who's my dad my dad is um
robert wilson bob wilson great dad
and from boston although we grew up in
dallas because my dad
worked in dallas and uh when we were
kids he was the head of the pbs station
in dallas just a great guy
yeah i miss him well i worked with ed
helms on that movie father figures
and
we just had a great time working
together it's funny kind of when you
show up to work kind of you know some
days you kind of look forward to it more
than others but when i was working with
ed i knew you know when i showed up was
going to be fun just kind of talking
sometimes it can be kind of awkward when
you're kind of left sort of sitting you
know in a car doing a scene when they're
not rolling but with ed and i
i don't know we just really got along
owen wilson
turkey movie free birds uh where i think
the tag line was hang on to your nuggets
pretty good
and uh
owen wilson zoolander quotes i mean the
one that people always say is uh han sol
so hot right now but i think that was
will ferrell who says that oh there's
something about with spider monkeys
like tripping with spider monkeys doing
chocolate mesclun or
i can't remember what it was oh who are
you trying to get crazy with essay don't
you know i'm loco
yeah and that came from that cypress
hill song
owen wilson and jennifer lopez together
again in marry me
and we worked in anaconda
and um
i think
this movie was about proving that that
chemistry that we
showed in anaconda wasn't just a fluke
owen wilson yellow jumpsuit
that would be bottle rocket but uh you
know i've worn a jumpsuit in a lot of
movies and i feel like it's always a
good um when i see that in my wardrobe i
feel like it's going to be a good movie
because i wore it in zoolander and
behind enemy lines i'm sort of wearing a
jumpsuit a flight suit with jackie chan
did i have one that seems like i had a
jumpsuit but they're saying no but yes
canary yellow jumpsuit and bottle rocket
owen wilson haunted house movie well
this is a genre that um that i'm
returning to i did um the haunting
and that wasn't wonderfully received and
so uh
you know a lot of people would have
maybe shied away from that genre but i'm
going back and this time we're going to
get it right although i think it still
did well
and it was fun uh there was a good cast
on on on that movie and i had fun doing
it
owen wilson bubba fett what's the
connection there
i don't know i mean
no not that i know of but i like that
character boba fett is like one of the
uh he's the bounty hunter right yeah so
as a kid you know that was like one of
the cool characters bubba fett great
name too bubba fett
what is owen wilson filming right now
i'm in new orleans and we're making a
movie called haunted mansion and what is
the source material for this is it a
book or is it this no it's actually a
ride a disney ride
what animal does owen wilson play
in fantastic mr fox i played coach skip
i think and the name of the game is uh
slap slap bat or slap back or
hot box no hotbox is something we played
as kids where it's like a man in the
middle that you're trying to tag out
what is owen wilson's middle name my
middle name is cunningham and that's my
mom's maiden name and luke and andrew my
two brothers they also have the same
middle name and you know when you're
like a kid and people kind of look up
your middle name in school so they would
kind of you know say richie cunningham
and stuff and make fun of it from happy
days
what color are owen wilson's eyes
blue
azure
does owen wilson play guitar no i don't
although um in starsky and hutch they
have me kind of uh
playing a guitar and i'm actually on the
soundtrack for starsky and hutch singing
a david soul song don't give up on me
baby i think and actually when i was in
australia i remember walking into a bar
and hearing like a song going god that
voice sounds familiar and it was my
voice although i'm not very musical and
my friend george streculius who did the
music on starsky and hutch said that i
broke three auto-tune machines trying to
get that song right does owen wilson
have tattoos i just have one tattoo that
i got in college on my shoulder a
four-leaf clover that says luck i wanted
it to say lucky and then i kind of
chickened out and just had it say luck
does owen wilson sing well i kind of
answered that uh that was part of my
guitar answer i wish i did sing or wish
i did sing well but i'll do karaoke and
if you can't sing that well you know a
good karaoke song one that i choose
tequila
because there isn't much singing all you
have to do is go tequila okay
that's it well that was just kind of a
real walk down memory lane for me and it
was great just kind of freestyling and
uh
kind of moonwalking and
you know going through that
[Music]